ich weiß noch gar nicht wie dieses video
als bei euch ankommt weil man könnte
sich auch denken warum erzählt etwas
über seine leute was klappt jetzt
bekommen beim neuen video für heute habe
ich mir mal wieder was ganz besonderes
heißt besonders als es ist mal wieder so
ein bisschen regelmäßig ich habe mir
gedacht ja komm du hast zuschauer die
sind etwas jünger du hast du schon die
sind so alt wie du du hast auch
zuschauer die sind 50 jahre alt du hast
noch zuschauer die sind sogar 70 jahre
also steht dass zumindest bei mir in den
analytics drin kann ich irgendwie ganz
glauben aber weil ich halt auch so ein
paar zuschauer haben die noch etwas
jünger sind so 10 11 12 13 14 oder so
oder vielleicht auch die etwas älteren
euch interessiert das ja bestimmt auch
wie das bei mir so was habe ich mir
gedacht ja kommen erzählt doch ein
format von einem ersten mal alkohol also
ich hab natürlich jetzt nicht so wie ihr
heutzutage mit zwölf damit angefangen
ich glaube ich war so ich glaube ich bin
gerade 15
ich kann mich nicht mehr genau erinnern
war halt so ein harter absturz wisst ihr
das weiß ich alles so klein ich will
euch natürlich nicht davon erzählen was
ich für heftige absturz hatte als ich
das erste mal alkohol getrunken habe
sondern ganz einfach so worauf man mal
ein bisschen achten sollte wie man das
ganze angehen zu hotel kein deutsch wie
man das ganze angehen sollte was man
sich davon so zu erhoffen hat und halt
wie es bei mir war
ich glaube es interessiert euch alle mal
so ein bisschen so klar ob wir fangen
einfach an metzger und zwar kann ich
mich daran erinnern als wäre es gestern
gewesen
aber es war schon vor drei jahren schon
gesagt ich bin da gerade 15 geboren und
meine freunde und ich wir dachten uns zu
york kommen lassen sie fahren also das
war so ein öffentlicher sehen mit
campingplatz und so und uns betrinken
komisch an aber man will das halt
unbedingt mal ausprobieren in dem alter
das haben wir dann halt auch gemacht
ein paar von den hatten auch vorher
schon mal alkohol getrunken also ich und
ich würde mal sagen das war so hälfte
hälfte also hälfte hatte alkohol
getrunken
die andere hälfte kann sich damit
überhaupt nicht aus und ja damit
weiterhin gefahren haben unsere zelte
aufgebaut und so weiter und dann keine
ahnung woher wie damals in algund hatten
auf jeden fall waren wir glaube ich zu
acht oder so und hatten halt bier dabei
aber auch so harten alkohol und wisst
ihr ich hatte wirklich so heftigen
respekt vor allem vor diesem wodka zeugs
oder so ich hatte da übelsten respekt
vor dass ich das so weiß ich nicht
meinen eltern habe ich halt so groß
gezogen so bier das es schlecht so oder
alkohol immer schlecht sodass darf sie
auf keinen fall trinken davon stirbst du
so ja okay vielleicht nicht ganz so
extrem aber es ging halt so
bisschen in die richtung ich werde mein
kind auch so groß ziehen also alkohol
ist schlecht das darfst du erst mit 16
und ich wahrscheinlich mal warte mal in
20 jahren wenn ich dann vater werde dann
ist das wahrscheinlich schon so dass die
schon mit sieben jahren alkohol trinken
wird ja immer schlimmer die jugend
gekommen scheißegal wir machen weiter
auf jeden fall waren wir dann halt
irgendwie an diesem zelt und so und dann
wird halt das bier rausgeholt und ich
weiß noch da wurde mir halten wir in die
hand gedrückt das war ein spiel das war
nicht mal richtiges bier und ich habe
getrunken
das war so das erste mal wo ich halt
wirklich diese klar man hat man mit zehn
jahren oder so bei seinem papa einen
schluck bier getrunken oder so aber das
war wirklich die erste flasche die ich
selber leer trinken sollte dann hab ich
davon drei stücke getrunken und dachte
mir so was ist das habt ihr da ein
gebiss das schmeckt übels scheiße ich
habe es wirklich nicht auf die kette
bekommen dieses mitspielt trinken weil
es einfach so eklig war und ich war
nicht der einzige dem das so ging das
ging halt wirklich mehreren so also ich
glaube wir waren zu dritt oder zu viert
und wir dachten uns erstmal das trinkt
man nicht wir fahren jetzt weg wir waren
dann irgendwie auf 8 über das essen kam
dann wieder da war es schon zähne oder
so und die anderen die alte geblieben
sind ich glaube wir sind da geblieben
vier waren halt essen
die waren schon so wiebels lustig drauf
und man merkt das war so ein moment
wüsste ich habe mir selber noch nie so
erlebt wenn du alten freund hast oder
ein kumpel so zehn jahre lang und den
immer halt im normalzustand erlebt und
plötzlich ist der komplett anders denkt
sich ja was geht so das ist ein
komisches gefühl sagt mal aber dann weiß
ich noch haben wir auch damit angefangen
dass einfach runter zu trinken und ich
hatte aber immer auch übelsten respekt
ich habe inhalts und bierchen getrunken
und vielleicht mal das und das so ich
weiß auch gar nicht wie dieses video
jetzt ankommt weil man könnte sich auch
denken warum erzählt etwas über sein
aber ich finde irgendwie wichtig so sein
wissen an leute weiterzugeben die halt
auch so davor stehen bzw einfach mal so
sein wissen zu teilen
wie war es bei euch ihr könnt ja auch
meine kommentare schreiben aber ich bin
noch gar nicht fertig eigentlich ja wie
gesagt ja wie gesagt ich hatte immer
noch übelsten respekt aber habt und was
getrunken und dann kam als so langsam so
dieses dieser leichte schwindel sag ich
mal so dass man immer gut drauf ist so
bisschen halt und da dachte ich dann
schon direkt bohr passt jetzt lieber auf
nicht dass du gleich komplett weg bist
oder so so überhaupt keinen sinn wenn
ich heute also ich kenne ja heute total
meine grenze und ich trinke auch klar
manchmal trinkt man alkohol aber nicht
zu viel aber da kann ich wirklich null
meine grenze und eigentlich hätte ich
auch noch mehr trinken können sobald das
war wirklich
nicht ich war halt leicht angetrunken
sag ich mal wir waren dann irgendwie im
wasser oder so und es war als witz ich
keine ahnung da habe ich das eigentlich
mehr gefeiert und dann wollte ich halt
noch mehr davon trinken
aber dann war irgendwie schon alles weg
ich war dann glaube ich so für
eineinhalb stunden angetrunken oder so
und finds halt richtig schade dass ich
nicht mehr davon trinken kann so weil
man es halt wirklich ausprobieren will
heutzutage sich das so das ist halt
wirklich gut war dass ich damals keinen
alkohol mehr bekommen habt weil dann
wurde ich halt so langsam herangeführt
konnte immer vielleicht ein bisschen
mehr ausprobieren ja keine ahnung
ehrlich gesagt weiß ich gar nicht mehr
so genau wie sich das dann entwickelt
hat ich weiß halt noch so mit 617 dann
hat man wirklich auch ab und zu mal
davon zu viel getrunken kann ich auch
wirklich knallhart sagen weil das wird
sich jeder von euch oder jeder der ist
vielleicht noch 14 oder 15 ist
vielleicht ok 14 oder 15 ist
wahrscheinlich schon heutzutage bisschen
zu alt dafür also an jeden der jetzt
vielleicht zwölf oder dreizehn des
tibeters auch merken wenn ihr vielleicht
16 uhr 17 sei dass ihr dann mal so eine
phase ab wo er ab und zu zu viel davon
konsumiert aber bei mir ist es ja zu ich
weiß wirklich wo meine grenzen sind und
ich hasste wirklich das gefühl wenn man
zu viel getrunken hat und allein aus
diesem grund halte ich es eigentlich
immer in maßen und das ist auch wirklich
wichtig also leute mit diesem video
wollte ich euch alkohol keineswegs gut
drehen ich wollte halt nunmal so bisher
so darauf aufmerksam machen so weit ich
weiß ganz genau jeder 12 oder 13 jährige
wünscht sich so ein bohr
ich will das jetzt endlich ausprobieren
aber geht da ganz gechillt dann macht es
doch erst mit 516 ich verstehe gar nicht
der sinn ist sich mit zwölf oder
dreizehn heutzutage schon zu betrinken
ich meine mit zwölf oder dreizehn
vertrag der graf war ein halbes bier von
wenn es dann wirklich ausprobiert geht
ganz langsam daran und schießt nicht
sofort ab weil das wird dann find ich
für euch bei euren eltern gegenüber wenn
ihr's mitbekommen und dann habt ihr
wahrscheinlich erst mal stress weil mit
15 oder so ist es ja noch illegal
das wars mit dem video das euch gefallen
hat wird sich sehr freuen wenn ihr
daumen nach oben geht
ihr könnt ihr eure erfahrungen mit
alkohol in die kommentare schreiben wie
das bei euch als das erste mal alkohol
konsumiert hat würde mich interessieren
hier oben links geht es auch weiter mit
meinem letzten match act ist auch auf
jeden fall ab snapshot und haben wir das
abo nicht vergessen wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder da kommen natürlich
auch wieder ein paar videos
nächste woche wird es etwas weniger da
ich mich noch ein bisschen auf meine
mündliche sportprüfung konzentrieren
muss aber wir sehen uns heute schon
sonntag